so when I worked the the for Showtime
the Logan Paul Floyd Mayweather fight I
was like the Logan Paul expert right so
I had to go in and interview Logan and
I'd go in there I was like I bet they're
gonna be a train wreck they're gonna be
so nervous to fight and Floyd May when I
walk in there and they had it was like a
yoga studio they had like incense
burning it was real calm and Logan's
like what's up man like dude you fight
in 30 minutes so getting it cool I'm
like I guess shouldn't you like warm up
he's like that's all good man I did a
couple downward dogs no I thought you
could be nervous he goes I've already
won dude I'm not nervous at all I've
already won he was I'm a YouTuber I'm
fighting Floyd Mayweather cool I've
already won dude he's like whatever
happens all good what an attitude I look
over he's like can you talk to my dad
though I look at that and he's just like
sweating so nervous I was like listen
your son's gonna be fine Floyd's time
he's not gonna give him brain trauma if
he hurts him it's gonna be to the body
he'll be fine if you think I was okay
he'll be fine he's gonna have liver
damage and internal bleeding he'll be
fine yeah yeah he can overcome that yeah